sortie sans france merci il ya beaucoup
de temps dans les termes suivants soir
dans son monsieur le président mes chers
collègues mais question s'adresse à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état en charge
des transports de la mer et de la pêche
le 16 novembre dernier au matin la
petite dame là âgé de 11 ans a perdu la
vie sur le chemin de son établissement
scolaire
fauché par un poids lourd en plein
centre de la ville du thillot sur la
rn66 ce drame qui n'est malheureusement
pas le premier sur ce tronçon confirme
la nécessité absolue de réaliser au plus
vite le projet de déviation du thillot
et de la rn 66 afin d'éviter la
traversée de plusieurs communes par des
milliers de poids lourds
cette divination situé sur l'axé benelux
balles soutenues par les élus constitue
un véritable enjeu pour la vallée de la
haute moselle en termes de développement
économique
également en terme de sécurité et
d'amélioration du cadre de vie des
habitants des territoires concernés en
permettant un report du trafic de
transit et du trafic des changes cet
aménagement offrir à des avancées
majeures en terme de sécurité routière
l'environnement et de désenclavement de
la vallée depuis plusieurs années les
élus nationaux et locaux milite pour une
inscription de ce projet déclaré
d'utilité publique dans le contrat de
plan état région
malheureusement ni le cpr signé en 2015
avec l'ex région lorraine
ni la clause de revoyure adopté
récemment lors de la création de la
région grand-est ne prévoit un
quelconque investissement pour les
infrastructures routières vosgienne ce
qui laisse présager un statu quo dans
les années à venir face à ce triste
constat
monsieur monsieur le ministre monsieur
secrétaire d'état quelles sont les
mesures que vous comptez mettre en
oeuvre pour éviter que de nouveaux
drames se produisent et quels sont les
autres modes de financement que vous
envisagez pour permettre la réalisation
de ce projet met ainsi la parole est à
monsieur andré vallini
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député le gouvernement partage bien sûr
avec la famille de la petite victime la
peine suscitée par l'accident dramatique
que vous avez rappelé survenu le 17
novembre dernier et qui a coûté la vie à
la petite dame là une fillette de 11 ans
qui se rendait à l'école
comme vous le savez le procès du
chauffeur routier s'est tenue le 13
décembre et une peine de prison avec
sursis a été requise à son encontre
le verdict est prévu pour le 9 février
prochain
aussitôt après l'accident les services
de l'état se sont mobilisés en lien avec
le département et la commune pour
prendre des mesures nécessaires à la
sécurisation des lieux la rn66 vous le
savez bien sûr relie remiremont à
l'autoroute a36 au droit de mulhouse
elle permet une traversée du massif
vosgien par le sud est comme le montre
l'analyse des trafics âge ou plutôt un
rôle de cabotage pour chacune des
vallées qu'un rôle de transit entre
l'alsace et la lorraine
c'est pourquoi l'état aurait entre grand
transit entre luxembourg et bâle vers
l'itinéraire eu 25 via m et strasbourg
intégralement aménagé en itinéraires
autoroutiers
le projet de déviation du thillot dont
vous avez parlé long de 10 km 500
s'étend depuis la fin de la déviation de
rupture moselle jusqu'au lieu-dit
plongeon sur la commune de saint maurice
sur moselle
ce projet doit permettre la déviation de
plusieurs communes qui supportent
aujourd'hui un trafic de 10 mille
véhicules par jour cette réalisation
déclaré d'utilité publique en juin 2013
est très attendue mais compte tenu de
son coût important 165 millions d'euros
elle n'a pu être inscrits au volet
routier du contrat de plan etat-région
2015 2020 pour autant et dans la mesure
où des crédits seraient disponibles au
moment de la révision du cpr dès l'année
prochaine
l'etat sera très attentif à la priorité
qui pourrait donner à cette opération
mais